pop
[Musique]
depuis plus de dix ans la citroën méhari
ces lotos vert mais cette traction avant
très légère à carrosserie plastique et
moteur dérivé de la deux chevaux n'était
pas à proprement parler une véritable
tout-terrain
voici désormais une vraie quatre roues
motrices que l'on reconnaît à la roue de
secours sur le capot et aux robustes
pare chocs techniquement la méhari 4 4 a
été très modifiée avec des suspensions
renforcées et surtout une nouvelle boîte
de vitesses avec réducteur rapport 2,6
et sorties de mouvement vers l'arrière
l'astuce de citroën a consisté à
intégrer l'arbre de transmission dans la
plateforme et l'on peut constater que le
soubassement se trouve
exceptionnellement dégagé avec le
différentiel et les freins arrière bien
protégé des chocs
par contre pas encore de moteur 36
chevaux type visa mais l'ancien 6 102
centimètres cubes 29 chevaux
admirez le tableau de bord très complet
avec compteur horaire de marchands 4,4
et surtout les commandes de transmission
levier de vitesse
réducteur ses lecteurs 4 2 4 4 et levier
de cabotage bloquant le différentiel
arrière pour se sortir des terrains
difficiles
on le voit bien la méhari cats iv
notamment d'étudier pour les besoins de
l'armée est une véritable quatre roues
motrices très sophistiqué où l'on à
pallier le manque de puissance par une
très forte des multiplications de
transmission tout en exploitant au mieux
la légèreté de cette voiture 715 kg en
ordre de marche et là où une deux roues
motrices se plante là 4,4 passes à
l'aise avec possibilité de réduction de
démultiplication et blocage de
différentiel pour les passages
particulièrement difficile
[Musique]
maniable car doté d'une bonne visibilité
la méhari 4,4 grâce à son centre de
gravité extrêmement bas pour un véhicule
tout terrain passe sans problème dans
les dévers les plus impressionnants
[Musique]
en fait son agilité vienne sa légèreté
et l'amérique at 4 passes
certes lentement mais en douceur là où
les quatre 4 classique utilise la force
ainsi à pleine charge
la mairie peut gravir des pentes jusqu'à
95%
c'est à dire pratiquement 45 degrés un
record
reste bien sûr les prix l'amérique at 4
ne sera commercialisé cannes octobre en
deux versions utilitaires à taux normal
de tva
trente six mille francs ou quatre places
mais à quarante cinq mille francs
[Musique]
oh
auj
[Musique]